at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by the
book how to lead by david
rubinstein david rubenstein is one of
the visionary founders of the carlyle
group and host of the david rubinstein
show where he speaks to leaders
from every walk of life about who they
are how they define success
and what it means to lead jeff bezos
richard branson
warren buffett bill gates ruth bader
ginsburg phil knight oprah all of them
and more
are featured in his new book titled how
to lead
this comprehensive leadership playbook
illustrates the principles and guiding
philosophies of the world's greatest
game changers
in this book's pages you can discover
the experts secrets to being effective
and innovative leaders
past podcast guest walter isaacson has
this to say
quote reading this invaluable trove of
advice from the greatest leaders of our
time
is like sitting in an armchair and
listening to the masters reveal their
secrets pick up a copy of how to lead
subtitle wisdom from the world's
greatest ceos founders and game changers
by david rubinstein
in hardcover ebook or audio anywhere
books are sold
hello ladies and germs boys and girls
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is normally
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types all
different
ilks all different sectors whatever you
get the idea in this special episode
the tables are completely turned instead
of interviewing someone else
i am interviewed by two experts on
several topics i've both studied
and supported for quite some time
including psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy and what it can do to heal
trauma and broadly speaking
possible futures for mental health we
cover
a lot i'm not a doctor i don't play one
on the internet
so this is for informational purposes
only
this audio was recorded on a new show
the psychedelic news hour
the psychedelic newshour dot com soon to
be a podcast
and i'm in conversation with two people
dr david rabin
md phd dr dave dot io you can find him
on instagram
at dr david rabin r-a-b-i-n a
board-certified psychiatrist and
neuroscientist executive director of
the board of medicine and co-founder of
apollo neuroscience
as well as dr molly malouf md dr mali.co
and on instagram dr molly dot co
a physician stanford lecturer and
ketamine assisted psychotherapist
this episode was recorded on an app
called clubhouse
you can find it at joinclubhouse.com an
app still
in private beta and defined by their
tagline which is
clubhouse is a space for casual drop in
audio conversations with friends and
other interesting people around the
world i don't have any stake
in this app wish i did i guess since i'm
giving it a free plug
this one's on me clubhouse one final
note i recorded this on my
phone a necessity for using the app so
the audio
quality is not studio quality but it was
polished as much as possible it is
listenable you'll be able to make it out
you should be fine so
thank you for understanding and thanks
to everyone who joined and asked very
thoughtful questions i had a lot of fun
doing this
and we covered a ton of ground that has
not been covered on this podcast before
so without further ado here we go
welcome back to another psychedelic news
hour on clubhouse
we are so so thankful and grateful to
have all of you join us
here again today i'm dr dave rabin
i'm a psychiatrist and neuroscientist as
well as a ketamine assisted
psychotherapist and an mdma assisted
psychotherapist
and i'm joined by my co-host dr molly
malouf
who is also a physician and a ketamine
assisted psychotherapist
and we are very excited and humbled to
bring to you our very special guest this
week
he has done some incredible work in the
psychedelic research space
and investment space and the mental
health space actually
which is where i think all of this ties
together and i think that
one of the things that we often forget
about
and i really wanted to tell you this tim
for a long time because i've been
following your work and i'm
so grateful for the fact that you've
done two major things that i think have
really radically transformed the
landscape of
mental health in this country and it's
not just mental health we're really
talking about
health because part of the problem with
health looking at mental health in the
and in the western paradigm is we
separate mental health and physical
health
where they're really just health and you
know mental health left unchecked over
time causes physical health problems and
physical health left
unchecked over time can cause mental
health problems and we know that this is
the case
and you had the courage a while back to
come out and
actually talk about your experiences
with mental health
in public and to have these
conversations and bring them to the
forefront
of our community so that other people
could
feel no longer afraid to start to have
these conversations
and i think that you know as a
psychiatrist
as somebody who does psychedelic work
and molly too
i speak for both of us uh when i say
that we could not be
more grateful and i don't think the
field of mental health could be more
grateful
to you and we should probably do in
terms of the field we should probably do
a better job of showing that gratitude
because you really
help destigmatize trauma and
destigmatize mental illness so that
people can feel comfortable talking
about this
in public settings and just more often
in general which is really the first
step along the healing process
and then you've transformed that by
taking the next step and
actually putting money and putting
resources and encouraging others to put
resources into the research development
and commercialization of these powerful
tools
that were also stigmatized heavily that
now can be used
to do something that we never thought we
could do in mental health which is tell
someone
that it's possible that there could be a
cure for what you're
experiencing right now and we may not be
there yet
but we're closer than we've possibly
ever been
and i just want to take this moment to
thank you
for all of your hard work and everything
you've done to
help facilitate this cause and to really
share
joy with the world of people who are
suffering right now so thank you
and please welcome tim ferriss thank you
very much i feel as someone who's spent
decades in darkness
experiencing many of the conditions that
these compounds
may have the capability to treat and
believing them as many
even in psychiatry
currently believe them to be intractable
or at the very best
treated with some type of suppression of
symptoms
it's an honor for me to play whatever
small role that i can
and it's also a moral imperative
i feel so it's been an incredible
journey
in every respect of the word and
i'm hoping to continue to be a
supporter and catalyst to the extent
that i can
so thank you for saying all that well
and speaking of that journey i think
we would be remiss if we did not start
out
by giving you the opportunity to update
everyone on clubhouse who is not
a party to the incredible announcement
by maps that you and joe greene played
such an important role in recently
would you mind telling everyone a little
bit about the capstone
and the great success that that has been
that was announced yesterday
my pleasure so there's a piece that does
a good job of
summarizing this in the wall street
journal it is
online by uh shalini ramachandran
which has the headlines silicon valley
and wall street elites pour money into
psychedelic research
and the subtitle gets closer to the
summary which is donors raised 30
million for psychedelic
non-profit that's maps to complete
clinical trials
phase 3 trials around drug assisted
psychotherapy for trauma that's mdma
assisted psychotherapy for
post-traumatic stress disorder so
certainly trauma of many different types
whether that's
war veterans first responders victims of
sexual abuse or otherwise any type of
abuse
certainly and the capstone campaign
was it's funny to say in the past tense
now
yeah the capstone campaign was a
campaign
to raise the 30 million dollars
necessary
complete phase iii trials of mdma
methyl dioxide methamphetamine otherwise
known as ecstasy
in the amplified psychotherapeutic
treatment of ptsd and
it's very important to emphasize that
this is not phase 3 trials 4
mdma is a standalone treatment it is the
combination
of context and molecule which is
extremely extremely important as i'm
sure you've discussed previously in
these meetings
and 30 million dollars is
or would have been even three years ago
an almost unthinkable amount of money
an unattainable amount of money to raise
for this
and i was going to say it took rick
almost what like 30 years to raise the
first 30 million
yeah exactly so you know a handful of
years ago the
number of people contributing or just
committing seven figures to psychedelic
research would have been
a handful and that has changed a lot in
the last two years i think that's a
credit to rick i think it's credit to
many things
in the increased de-stigmatization of
supporting
the scientific research there are many
things one can support within the realm
of let's call it psychedelics or
psychedelic science
which i think is part of the reason
there's a lot of scattered focus
and historically in some cases a lack of
results
it's because you can you can go a
millimeter in a million directions very
easily if you don't focus
but in this case the piece summarized
some very notable names who have
contributed
a lot and what i would like to
personally underscore about this
is that there were donors and donations
made
from one dollar all the way up to five
million
and there were more than 2500 donors
including probably
many people listening to this put their
trust after
reading or hearing what they evaluated
into supporting this and every donor
mattered and the number of donors to me
is just as important as the number of
dollars raised because it signals to me
a real phase shift in the the cultural
conversation about these compounds
uh we don't have to revisit the sort of
historical mistakes
that were made in say the 60s
nor the cultural context then which is
very different from the cultural context
now but
i think it's very exciting that more and
more people are realizing that it is
actually
an incredible reputational opportunity
to align yourself
with exploring these unconventional
treatments
for extremely expensive
sometimes fatal often paralyzing
conditions that we
seem utterly unable to treat properly
via other beings
currently so the fact that we have such
an incredibly low toxicity profile
for if we're talking about empty main
psilocybin specifically because
let's not forget that there are hundreds
and thousands of
what we could call psychedelic compounds
among those
two that have received breakthrough
therapy designation by the fda
with vast amounts of data to support
their clinical use
have incredible safety profiles low
toxicity
certainly you're going to find many more
people in emergency rooms
because of acetaminophen tylenol which
can be incredibly toxic compared to any
of these
and the fact that they have the results
they appear to have if you look at say
phase two data
from maps would lead one to believe
either
that people are lying right they're
misrepresenting the results they cannot
be true
or something is happening that defies
any conventional psychiatric or
psychological explanation for how
the brain changes and how thoughts
and thought patterns change the
capability of humans to rewrite their
software
to rewrite the stories they tell
themselves with incredible
durability of effect right in the case
of mdma or psilocybin i'd say hopkins
you're looking at one to three total
treatment sessions with durability of
various effects 6 months 12 months 18
months later
that is more interesting to me than just
about anything else i could possibly
focus on
so i'll stop my my monologue there
you're you're absolutely right tim i
mean it's it's phenomenal it really
demonstrates or highlights what we're
seeing as this complete paradigm shift
in mental illness and i can say as a
western trained psychiatrist you know
we're taught
to tell people that you prescribe
medicine or therapy
and you tell people that the studies
show that if they discontinue medicine
or discontinue therapy
at any time that their chances of
relapse
go up and the severity of their relapses
will likely go
up and what we're seeing from mdma
for those who are not familiar with the
phase two trial results is that
people who have had treatment resistant
ptsd for an
average of 17 years something like 53
percent
are no longer meeting diagnostic
criteria after just three doses of mdma
and 12 weeks of psychotherapy as
as you were saying and what's even more
remarkable is five
years out without any more subsequent
treatment
67 of these people are
no longer meeting diagnostic criteria
and from
having trained in the mdma protocol and
the ketamine assisted psychotherapy
protocol which were very very similar
i can tell you that my perspective on
this which i think is very similar to a
lot of the practitioners
who work in this area is the reason why
this works so differently is because
we're actually teaching people how to
heal themselves we're reminding them of
this
innate as mike and andy mithoffer say
the inner healing intelligence that we
were all born with
has the capacity to be reactivated when
we recognize that it's there
and this allows us an opportunity to
start to heal ourselves because the
center of our healing we now
recognize comes from within us not from
some pill
that we have to take every day and not
from some person we have to see every
week but
actually from within ourselves which is
so remarkable
it is and i want to underscore something
you said or two names you mentioned
annie and michael mithoffer who are
incredible practitioners
i should say therapists and who have
helped define and formalize the format
for the psychotherapy that is assisted
by
mdma in these mass trials and i do
whenever i can try to
play the role of conservative voice in
media related to psychedelics because i
do not view
psychedelics as panacea i do not think
they're suitable for all people
and it's very easy to throw the
baby out with the bath water by
viewing psychiatry as it exists or
therapy as it exists as obsolete and i
think that's a
huge mistake because the results that
are achieved
are i think in many cases dependent
on tools from therapy or psychiatry
like internal family systems ifs
parts work these types of conversations
when conducted this type of self-inquiry
when
aided by a therapist with the impathogen
let's just call it of mdma something
that generates empathy not just towards
others but that can be directed at the
self within the self
is incredibly potent and it is the
combination it is the combination
this is why if you go to an edm festival
it's not automatic that a thousand
people on ecstasy are resolving
all of your childhood trauma doesn't it
just doesn't work that way
nor does every pothead who tries
in all due respect to potheads but like
any any pothead in college who tries
mushrooms once doesn't automatically
stop smoking
but on the other side when you look at
the nicotine addiction studies that have
been done
with proper planning format support and
integration and follow-up
by say dr matt johnson at hopkins
the results are staggering they are
literally staggering
so i just want to take that opportunity
to indicate that we can borrow best
practices
from psychiatry and therapy and
effectively put them on
performance-enhancing drugs by adding
some of these compounds with the right
safety profiles and certainly ketamine
is is of interest to me as well
yeah i love everything you guys are
saying because the thing that we've
always emphasized in the
newshour is it's just fundamentally
important that people recognize that the
best outcomes come from
therapy plus medicine but i'm curious to
both of you guys just to ask from both
of you because i know you're
probably even more well versed than i am
on all the research even though i've
read through quite a lot of it
do you guys want to explain to the
audience how these studies have been
performed
and assume that there's some scientists
out there in the audience i'm sure
there's some people that are questioning
and wondering about
okay so how was the study done was there
a control
of just medicine or control of just
therapy can you teach people a little
bit about how
this has been performed so that people
can kind of get a better understanding
of the specific research yeah i'm happy
to share one aspect of it
that is very valid uh an important
part of the conversation and then i'd
love to hand the mic off because
i'm i am on the line with two doctors
and i'm most certainly not a doctor and
do not play one on the internet
but have spent a lot of time looking at
and being involved with study design
just as a funder of a lot of this
research
because you have to pick and choose your
targets you have to pick and choose your
study design
very very carefully you don't get an
infinite number of investments
for leverage in science just like you
don't get in business
these things cost a lot of money and
they take a lot of time so you have to
really
think about your parameters from the
outset well let me give the short answer
first
yes these are placebo controlled
randomized studies
and the intervention the active
intervention let's just say mdma is
contrasted with a placebo combined with
the
same therapy the same therapeutic
approach and
the placebo effect is the the most
consistent powerful
effect across all of medicine so we need
to
take it very seriously and there are
entire books written about
placebo and nocebo which is the opposite
of that where you can negate
the say pharmacological intervention by
believing that it doesn't work which is
just as crazy if you begin to think
about it
yet real and blinding and including
placebo
in psychedelic studies is remarkably
challenging
because it is very quickly obvious to
almost everyone whether or not they've
been given a psychedelic
even if they have had no prior exposure
if they do enough reading and so on
uh rick would be much more qualified to
talk about this but there are ways to
use what one might deem an
active placebo to create a physiological
effect
uh such as by using something like
niacin
right where you have skin flushing
so-called niacin flush
and these types of active placebos can
be used i think particularly well
with respect to mdma it is more
challenging
when you are using what we might
consider a classic psychedelic with
strong visionary or visual components
such as psilocybin but i would love to
pass the mic because that's where i feel
like i start wading
into the deep end of my ignorance pool
so i'd prefer to divert the ice yeah
thank you so much for that tim i think
you covered
the great majority of it actually and i
think bringing up placebo and nocebo
and the importance of those things is
really critical because i think what a
lot of people
don't understand is that placebo and
nocebo are really
having a factor in the study design that
takes into account the power of belief
in our treatments so placebo is really a
matter of saying in a western scientific
lingo
that you know if you believe a treatment
is going to work for you then it's going
to work
it's 30 to 50 percent of the time more
likely to work if you believe in it and
these are the numbers roughly for mental
health studies and for
nocebo i think the numbers are actually
a little higher which means if you
believe that a treatment will not work
for you
it is 30 to 50 percent less likely to
work
which is really fascinating that it's
really the power of the mind in the
healing process right getting back to
what we were talking about before
is using this combination of
psychotherapy
to enable or amplify the
power of the medicine and in turn using
the medicine in the case of mdma to
catalyze
the radical safety and radical healing
potential for psychotherapy
to facilitate these incredible healing
experiences of people
that are really rooted in intention and
belief
which goes back to a lot of the tribal
history of how
traditional psilocybin and cactus
ceremonies and ayahuasca ceremonies are
performed it's all about
intention to heal and curating a safe
space for that intention to manifest
in healing and that you can see that
consistently when you look in
how these mdma trials are put together
it really
pulls that intentionality that is rooted
in these traditional tribal cultures
in their ancient healing practices that
are who knows probably 5
10 twenty thousand years old it pulls
those in as best as we can
into a western paradigm that's double
blinded and
placebo controlled and and randomized
where
you know subjects get this incredible 12
weeks of psychotherapy
protocol you know the results for people
going through just to compare i said
earlier of the people who have 17 years
plus
on average of treatment resistant ptsd
in the maps phase 2 trial with mdma
what we saw was that two months after
this treatment wrapped up in the active
group that actually received mdma
and again this these were crossover
studies so
all the subjects got mdma eventually
um but there were also groups of
subjects that got placebo first and some
groups got
placebos second which is typically in
these studies and correct me if i'm
wrong i believe it was
low-dose mdma which was not critical
enough to hit the threshold
mdma is a really interesting molecule
because it's you have to hit
a threshold to be able to get the active
effect which makes mdma probably the
worst medicine to microdose because
it has a paradoxical effect where you
kind of don't feel good if you take
too little of a dose and you don't hit
that threshold peak dose
which is somewhere between 80 and 120
milligrams for most people
and so they use that as the placebo but
what's really interesting is
that in these people who had 17 years on
average of treatment resistant ptsd
we see that 53 who had the active
mdma two months out are no longer
meeting
diagnostic criteria for ptsd i believe
that in the placebo group
that only received the sub-therapeutic
dose of mdma
what we saw was something like 20
something percent i think was like 25 or
27
were no longer meeting diagnostic
criteria which is actually pretty
amazing
because that means that the therapy
alone this 12 weeks of intensive therapy
with two therapists is actually very
powerful at helping people
but then you go and look at the
five-year follow-up data which is really
where it counts
and what you see is the people who did
not get mdma at five years out
they did not continue to get better in
fact many of the 27
that were no longer meeting symptom
criteria at the end of that first 12
weeks
actually relapsed and ultimately had a
recurrence of ptsd symptoms whereas
more people who got mdma were
symptom-free or not meeting diagnostic
criteria
five years out then were at two months
out which then goes to continuously
reinforce this idea that
the medicine and the therapy and the
intention to heal
are facilitating this radically
transformative experience that allows
people to remember how to heal
themselves which is just such an
incredible opportunity in mental health
we've really never seen anything like
this before i think it's
super interesting just to tie this up
that if you look at the s-ketamine
research you know this drug came along
by j j
and it was frankly just not a very good
drug because it's not much better than
regular ketamine
and like they didn't combine it with any
therapy and doctors aren't really using
it that much
especially the doctors in the kettering
space because it's basically designed to
just go to the clinic take the medicine
and go home
and that's what's so inspiring about
this map's research
is by its design it's combining these
two therapeutic modalities in order to
create the best
effects long-term to most people who ask
me
should i do x fill on the blank
should i do should i use solo 7 should i
use
dmt should i use i was should i use
mdma generally speaking i would say 90
plus percent of the time after i
ask a few follow-up questions my answer
is no
which might be surprising to people
given how public i am about supporting
research
and the reason for that is pretty simple
i think that there's a lot of
preparation you can do to increase the
odds
of a very good outcome much like
if you're going to bet in a casino you
should probably read a few books
beforehand do a little bit of role
playing
maybe some rehearsal online play for
real stakes to see how your psychology
changes and then maybe
you consider going to the casino and
only then should you even consider
a game where you might have might if you
are
exceptional have a chance of bending the
odds right so you're playing blackjack
single deck blackjack instead of slop
slot machine or the roulette wheel and i
think a lot of people play roulette with
psychedelics and i think it's a terrible
idea
for the following reason a simple way to
think about psychedelics i'm not saying
this is
scientifically comprehensive because
it's not it's it's a metaphor
but what psychedelics do and this is
whether you're dealing with tryptamines
or where you're dealing with
phenethylamines but i think particularly
tryptamines in a lot of contexts uh we
could put sul7 in that category
certainly
dmt dimethyltroop domain would fall into
that category these compounds
mdma although it's i consider it a
pathogen
i'm more than a psychedelic is similar
in respects what it's doing is heating
up the clay
of your your mind and psyche and brain
structurally also such that it's more
malleable
and you can reshape these narratives
and stories and behaviors
that have governed much of your life and
many of these stories many of these
narratives many of these
behaviors compulsive loops whether that
compulsion manifests as ocd
eating disorder treatment resistant
depression chronic anxiety
alcoholism or otherwise i happen to
think that these are all
symptoms of a shared underlying set of
issues
these psychedelics heat up the clay so
that you can
re-mold those stories most of which you
never chose for yourself they were
absorbed somehow
or caused by the environment trauma in
childhood for instance
absolute parent whatever it might have
been and then the question is you've
heated the clay what do you do to ensure
it is remolded
in the most beneficial way possible
right do you have
an expert sculptor with lots of
experience helping you
right if we think about it as a keyboard
or rewriting a story like do you have
a seasoned proofreader helping you or do
you have a cat running across the
keyboard
which is how a lot of people take
psychedelics just play roulette
or we're still are you an environment
that is utterly unsupportive
where if you have mischievous friends
who want to prank you
or you have negligent friends who have
taken a compound
and are enjoying the experience and
don't want to be taken down by the
trauma that is surfacing for you
if that's the case it's important to
realize that the clay can be
molded into a misshapen form that is
worse than your
original state i think this is really
important to emphasize
right so you're introducing a period of
plasticity in the brain where it is
flexible
and then the question or one of the
questions is what are you doing
beforehand during and afterwards to
ensure that you're shaping it in the
most beneficial
way possible and for that reason if
people aren't willing to do
quite a lot of upfront preparation
to take it seriously to allocate
sufficient time
for a very spacious on-ramp and off-ramp
from the experience
in other words you're not having your
first psychedelic experience as five as
five immediate dmt
on a sunday night and then going into
your office in mail on monday morning
only then and in addition to that
committing to post care
having a therapist psychiatrist or
otherwise on board as a safety net so
that they
have a support structure that is not one
of their volunteer friends
will i recommend that someone consider
use of psychedelics that is how
seriously i take them
and that's not to mention the quality of
the medicine on the street these days
is so patchy and you're really rolling
the dice
every time you go and try
a psychedelic that you've procured
through the dark web through
your drug dealer through wherever you
get your medicine
you just don't know what equality is and
especially with mdma which is notorious
for having
adulterants in it and other sorts of all
sorts of things that people cut it with
so that too yeah it pays to
trend carefully and thoughtfully and i
do think that
caution is the better part of valor here
and
that just to continue to lay on the
metaphors
measuring twice and cutting once
accounts for a lot because in controlled
settings
with proper supervision with the pre and
post
carefully thought through which means
it's not impromptu there is a plan
just like you would have a plan going
into reconstructive knee surgery you
would have
prehab surgery you would have medication
to assist post-op
and intraop and you would have a
significant amount of attention
dedicated
pre-operation to your rehabilitation i
look at this the same way
and if you don't do that although it's
not maybe as
common to read about or hear about these
stories
you can end up very dislocated you can
end up
becoming unmoored and i have seen first
hand i've seen dozens of lives directly
changed
in ways that are inconceivable based on
the textbooks
of psychology and psychiatry used in
colleges today for instance or medical
schools
inconceivable and that tells me that
that as any good doctor would tell you
like 50
of what we know is wrong we just don't
know which 50
right i mean it was like we operated on
newborns and infants without anesthesia
until 1987. let's not forget right i
mean we
are still in the medical dark ages in
many respects
and that will always be the case there
will be great unknowns of great value
and i think that
many of them are in psychedelics on the
opposite end of the spectrum i've seen
people get
so destabilized and knocked sideways
that they are effectively
in a psychotic state for days
weeks or in a handful of cases years
afterwards
generally associated with ayahuasca and
getting lost
in that world in south america so it is
very smart it is very tactically
useful to do your homework and
if you want to go fast to borrow from
the military like
slow is smooth and smooth as fast you
could not be
more right there tim and i thank you for
echoing
a sentiment that we talk about
frequently on the newshour because
that's
you know what you're mentioning is
really one of the most common mistakes
that i think people make
with the psychedelic medicines and i
think your metaphor about
the clay remolding the clay warming the
clay is
such a good one because you know our
brains really learn
more i think in metaphor than in any
other way and
that metaphor of of warming the clay
giving the opportunity for the clay to
take a new shape or for us to
effectively reshape it reform it and
then have it solidify
in the way that we want or intend it to
be in the future
that's aligned with our goals maybe not
as much aligned with
whatever we absorbed you know in the
first several years of our lives from
whoever happened to be around us at
those times or whatever we were seeing
on tv or what have you or in our schools
but actually what we want
ourselves to be not knowing what our
potential really
is um is just such a powerful metaphor
and i really
appreciate you bringing that up because
that is such a great way to think about
this
and i think you know interestingly i
think that metaphor actually plays into
a lot of different other areas of
of our lives speaking of which we're
kind of stuck in a mold for a long time
in the scientific
and medical community where research
only was done a certain way
you know research was only funded a
certain way it was only
conducted at certain places in certain
contexts
and so a lot of these different
approaches kind of got left out and were
not even evaluated
and the clay wasn't even ever really
warmed thoroughly for us to
have an opportunity to say hey maybe
there's a different way we could be
doing this
and then someone like you comes around
and says hey guys wait a minute
if i take some money and some of my
friends money and we
put it towards this stuff then all of a
sudden
it doesn't really matter what the nih or
the nimh says
we can make new research happen why is
it so important or more important than
ever right now
to have diverse sources of research
funding in the mix
i'll take a stab at it i appreciate you
setting that up so nicely
and before i do that just a quick
recommendation for a few resources for
people who might be contemplating
psychedelics or
perhaps are engaged but want to increase
their exposure to perhaps a few
different inputs that could be helpful
the healing journey by claudio and
n-a-r-a-n-j-o
is an exceptional book i highly
recommend the introduction alone
makes any cost associated very cheap
secret chief both of these are actually
published by maps
and it just so happens not because
they're published by maps but because
they're
great books and i'm recommending them
the secret chief which is a
discussion of different modalities of
facilitation
and i would also recommend to anyone who
is engaged with or considering being
engaged with psychedelics that you
download the waking up app by sam harris
and do the introductory course
10 minutes a day for i think it's
between 30 and 50 days
this will help you navigate and squeeze
the most juiced from
your experiences particularly when
combined with a book
called awareness by anthony demello so
do those two concurrently
back to your question why are diverse
sources of funding
important well i would say first
that the citizen philanthropy the
capital from individual donors is
important
first and foremost because there's such
a lack
of funding from many other sources and
my intention with committing
many millions of dollars of my own
capital the largest
such commitment to anything for-profit
or non-profit in my life
certainly especially beginning a few
years ago whether it's
hopkins imperial college the phase iii
trials with
maps and mdmas psychotherapy the
intention
is to provide seed capital to something
that can be a world changer just as i
would in the world of startups
my goal is to give 50k to something that
i think can raise
50 million no problem a few years later
and
therefore the objective has been to pave
the way
through destigmatizing and
reputationally de-risking not just
de-risking but
clearly showing the reputational upside
of supporting this science as an
individual
to grease the wheels for individuals
then foundations then larger foundations
that have more reputation management
in place and more systems and processes
at these larger name brands dynastic
wealth foundations
and ultimately government agencies so
my plan starting at least a year ago
probably 18 months ago
has been to try to set
certain things in motion that will
likely increase the odds of federal
funding
within say three to five years i hope
closer to three years
and i'm very optimistic about that
nonetheless as it stands right now the
research
that we are seeing is almost entirely
dependent on
individuals finding conviction in the
data
sometimes in their own experiences to
look at this
as an opportunity to bend the arc of
history
from a mental health perspective much
like pharmacology
within medicine can be separated into
pre-antibiotics post antibiotics
and that was addressing physical bugs
for the sake of simplicity
if we're addressing mental and
psycho-emotional bugs right
fixing the software i think psychedelics
have
the potential to mark that type of
before and after
line and it's up to individual
philanthropists right now
much in the same way that oral
contraceptives were up to
catherine mccormick who's an incredible
woman everyone should read her wikipedia
from her history at mit
to ultimately almost single-handedly
developing oral contraception
with the equivalent of i want to say 24
million dollars in today's money
adjusting for inflation over a period of
like five or ten years and
it was initially approved if my memory
serves me
for the indication of menstrual
disorders and this is super important
and
ties into the strategy of how to
shepherd some of these compounds through
byzantine regulatory affairs although
the fda has been incredibly supportive i
want to
add that they're not the enemy here
they've been incredibly supportive of
both psilocybin and mdma
that the initial indication is very
important and
that bent the arc of history you think
about the long-term global effects
of that type of liberation for
half of our species in the form of
oral contraception being able to family
plan with that as a tool in this toolkit
for
such a small dollar amount right i mean
that is like one
in 10 billion out and i look for that
startups
and look for that in science and i
should say the psychology is not the
only place
i have allocated capital and place bets
in the world of scientific research but
they are the primary focus
so for that reason if anyone is sitting
on the sidelines for now
and they've been considering where they
might want to put their capital
you can't take your marbles with you and
we're all going to die and you could be
buried like a pharaoh with
you know golden thrones and gold bars
and so on but it's
probably not gonna help you very much i
think this is a
golden window of time over the next
let's just call it
one to three years where people can go
down in history
as having been the spark that kind of
lit the bonfire that
lit the world on fire in the most
productive way possible
that is so inspiring and you know i
think the
dovetail on that is the real kind of big
question that
plagues me every day as i'm thinking
about trying to figure out how are we
going to go from 100 hours of therapy
to hundreds of thousands of people who
have trauma
right now from what's happening in our
country over the next five years
like we can get these drugs approved but
the reality is
that the delivery of these medicines you
just look at our healthcare system right
now
i mean it's failing at its most basic
function which is to
treat sickness and so what is your
vision
of how this gets to scale because that's
the real question
that i think is going to truly lead to
whether or not like this changes the
world or we're stuck with
expensive treatments for only people can
afford it and that's what i'm trying to
figure out right now is
do we need to design new studies that
enable
groups of people to have treatments
together i mean if you look at
indigenous cultures ayahuasca is
delivered in groups
and so i kind of have an issue
personally with i know we have to design
studies that will get approved by the
fda but i have a really hard time
understanding how we're going to get
this scale with that current
i haven't take a stab at it i think this
is a better question
for the maps professionals but i can
give you
my lens through which i look at this or
the lenses
the first is that this may sound strange
given what i just said but
the scale and believe me i can count so
i know i'm getting this
off slightly but i can be a four letter
word and
seth godin talks quite a bit about how
easy it is to escape
into the big as opposed to focusing on
the small in front of you
right and even airbnb before it was
airbnb
focused on doing things that didn't
scale and there's actually
an excellent episode of the masters of
scale podcast by reed hoffman
with interviews of brian chesky and the
other founders of airbnb about doing
things in the beginning that did not
scale
very deliberately that might seem
antithetical to becoming very big but in
fact it is not
it is necessary for prototyping and
refining
and throwing a lot against the wall so
that you can build on early successes
so the things that we do in the
beginning are almost certainly not going
to be the things
at least not copy and paste that are
done three years later nor five years
later that's
the first assumption i would say that
i'm making
the second is that it is very
challenging to scale in person period
full stop so i don't expect it to be
easy that's just another assumption is
that this is not going to be easy and
then if something appears easy
we should double down on scrutiny and
really stress test it because there are
probably weaknesses
third is looking at historic
adoption of different behaviors and
systems
like it or hate it or even if you're
neutral
many many many things that end up at
scale like recycling in the united
states
started as something piloted
in very very small communities and
generally
in affluent areas right and that i think
these days can produce a visceral
negative response
but it's important to realize that the
more affluent
generally speaking are going to have
more capital more time
with which they can use to serve as
guinea pigs if that makes sense
right you're not going to ask the single
mom before to be a guinea pig it would
be unfair it would be unreasonable and
it'd be
extremely problematic right so a lot of
the
guinea pigs end up being small ish
groups of people with more capital and
time and i think that's okay if you look
at
startups in the very early stages they
very often
use the initial premium pricing
for a small subset of people to
completely pay for the r d and subsidize
developing cheaper versions that can be
deployed more widely
that's certainly true with uber which i
know very very well
since i was one of the initial advisors
so i saw them deliberately do that but
in the beginning
they caught incredible flack for being
elitist in that respect but suffice to
say that was an effective strategy it's
a strategy that we've seen
over and over again in different areas
and i would expect for us to see it in
psychedelic therapy as well and the
ultimate form that it takes
i don't know but another base assumption
that keeps me going quite frankly with
all that i'm involved with with respect
to psychedelic science
and indigenous communities and
psychedelics there's a lot that i
haven't talked about publicly that i'm
involved with but even if we just look
at the forward-facing stuff
it's very time consuming it's very
energy intensive it's very capital
hungry and part of what keeps me going
is the realization which is not a
cop-out in any sense because i do want
to
reach millions of people ultimately but
not
rush it and self-incinerate in the
process is that to change the world
you do not need to treat 100 million
people if you
can help one person overcome paralyzing
trauma
you've changed the world full stop the
ripple effect from that one person
can be incredible right let's say that
one person is the daughter of
a senator or congress person
who has lifelong eating disorder
multiple brushes with death multiple
hospitalizations
and psychedelic therapy is able to allow
that person to find
peace and rewrite their narrative such
that they're not battling this demon
every day that's one person
technically but what are the
far-reaching implications of that
there are many right if it's helpful at
any point if we want to talk about
ayahuasca we can talk about that as well
there are a number of people in the
psychedelic science world
researchers who are looking at group
integration and i think that's very
important to your point
and so that is going to happen it's
going to happen
and it is happening and i'm sure that
there are multiple researchers who are
looking at the effectiveness and cost
effectiveness of
operating in groups not necessarily for
treatment sessions but certainly for
prep and more frequently integration uh
i am
optimistic that in some cases groups
will not just be as effective
but more effective than one-on-one or
one-on-two meaning one patient and two
facilitators integration i'm very very
optimistic
and i think one of the ways the the
various
actions of the psychedelic movement will
hurt each other
and themselves and hobble things
is by trying to boil the ocean at once
if you try to go too big too fast
that is a recipe for disaster in my
opinion now i'm still aggressive i'm
[ __ ] aggressive it's how i am with
this type of thing i'm very aggressive
so i push
i really push but there is a point at
which you can push too hard and things
can break
it's a balance and it's a challenge for
me as well that is
a really beautiful answer and part of
why i'm so inspired by it is
you know my own medical practice has
always been fairly elitist
and it weighs on me a lot because i have
charged a lot of money for
you know early adoption of technologies
that now are becoming
scalable and what's really cool is that
there's a lot of companies that are
taking things that i've been doing
manually and they're digitizing them so
i think there is a lot of hope and
promise and i think the hard part
getting into early adopter
is that you see the future and you know
what's
coming and you just so badly want it to
be now because
never have we ever seen so much trauma
all at once and it's just heartbreaking
to see society right now
with so much pain and knowing we have to
wait for this
and i know that's what's necessary but
it's still painful and watching
so much pain in the world it's like you
just want to alleviate it as a doctor
that's kind of why you went to medical
school
yeah and i would just say for anybody
listening you know historically
i think many participants in the
psychedelic space and there are i use
the word factions very deliberately
because i find the infighting within the
psychedelic world particularly
hilarious and hypocritical but
nonetheless we're humans and tribal and
all of that
that one of the greatest weaknesses
in the psychedelic world is having
everything become a priority
and trying to do everything if
everything is your priority
nothing is your priority and i'm not
saying that to you specifically molly at
all
it's just a lead into a broader
observation
of why these psychedelic subcultures
coordinating the different pieces can
often be like hurting cats
is because there is a pervasive lack of
focus
so pick your shots if you have your
patience and you're doing a good job
with your patients then you are doing a
good job
period so i want to just if that is any
reassurance
yeah tim i want to echo what molly was
saying and i really appreciate
your perspective on that because i think
it is a unique perspective i
for one have had these conversations
about scaling with lyanna who just
joined us to provide the maps framework
for
planning for scaling these kinds of
things since tim you brought it up
and also with rick doblin and you know
really talking about how we can expand
access and i think what always comes
back to me
is reminding myself of what are these
medicines really trying to teach us
and there has been this constant pattern
of ancient knowledge that keeps coming
to
me through the work that i work with my
own clients with and without medicine
and also through
some of the experiences that i've had in
my own trainings for example training
for ketamine assisted psychotherapy
where
you know it really comes back to these
tribal tenets of ancient wisdom which
are
gratitude forgiveness compassion and
self-love as the foundation of
trust that all of this is built on not
only
trust in ourselves it allows everything
else to grow from a stable foundation
but also
trust in everything else that we're
doing and trust in each other
and trust in this whole adventure that
we're on together that we can do this
together
and the interesting one of those four
that i think people
including myself have the most trouble
with on a regular basis
is self compassion because
self-compassion is most commonly on a
moment-to-moment day-to-day basis
really the practice of patience for
allowing things to unfold as they will
in time with focus and with dedication
and devotion but without rushing because
when we rush we make mistakes and that
patience and allowing that time and
opportunity for that compassion to come
into our lives allows us to recognize
and take a breath and take a step back
and say you know what
there is no rush right now you know we
have a lot to do
and there's a lot of other people
helping and there's a lot of work on the
horizon and a lot of things that we need
to do
but there is no rush and the more we can
be patient with this process
and all work together to see it through
not quickly
but effectively then the better this
will be for everyone but i just wanted
to
thank you for bringing up the patience
driven approach and reminding us of that
and i just wanted to
give lyanna an opportunity to quickly
catch us up on
map's plan concepts for scaling some of
these treatments more effectively
yeah thanks so much for calling me up hi
tim good to see you here i am
i really appreciate this conversation
that's being had right now in the
direction of this
and molly i really hear i mean there is
such incredible
need and i see it every day with the
amount of messages
and i work with another group that works
with veterans and there is a very urgent
need for these treatments
and just two quick points on scaling
that i wanted to bring in
is one let us remember that the mdma
protocol was first developed 14 years
ago and it's taken a very long time
to get this work to where it is and it
was developed in the model
with the dual therapists in the room for
the eight hour sessions
with the understanding to create the
most comprehensive protocol that had the
highest likelihood
of success within the fda framework and
so it was coming from that place it was
highly stigmatized it took a long time
to get the research to where it is today
so i just wanted to bring that piece in
and then also to say that
there is an unknown factor to see what
happens when
we start treating thousands tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people with mdma
and this controlled growth model that
we're working with which
there are some natural frictions built
into the rate in which we can adequately
train
therapists due to the need for
supervision and there's only
so many participants in our studies so
there's only so many opportunities for
therapists
to receive supervision in their training
we want to be prepared
for any adverse events and we want to
shore up the potential for there to be
backlash against this work
so that we can continue the success into
the future and so
it will be a very controlled kind of
growth model there will be a very
limited amount of therapists available
to do this work on day one of fda
approval but then
quickly after that it will start to grow
exponentially
so it will take time and patience is
needed and that's a hard thing when
there's so much need but it is the way
to do
this work right and i just tim i really
appreciated your comments
on all of that so thanks thanks leona
yeah
it's nice to see you first of all and
hear you you know it's
from a long-term planning perspective it
is i think
important to scenario plan
meaning anticipate that there are going
to be some
significant challenges and significant
blow back in different forms
as this scales as there would be with
anything new
it's the same reason that there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people who die
on highways in the united states i don't
know what the time frame would be week
day month but nonetheless it is stadiums
full of people who die
in automobile accidents but if one
person dies in a tesla
that has some degree of autonomous
driving it is news
and headlines everywhere and i fully
anticipate
that even though you could go to any er
and find
both critical patients and deaths caused
by things that you can purchase over the
counter
like acetaminophen and liver failure
associated with that
when there are and it's not if when
there are
human tragedies associated with
psychedelics
because there's a certain scale achieved
just given the law of large numbers
there are going to be
complications there are going to be
cases that get
a massively disproportionate response
from the media in negative coverage
these things are going to happen
if we are successful in making this
widely available
okay that is part of the i wouldn't say
a reward but a natural
outgrowth of this reaching some degree
of scale
and so while it pays to be optimistic
and there are many reasons to be
optimistic from a planning perspective
this is going to be
if it is successful very challenging we
will need to have
very organized groups of people like
those who are doing
drug development and handling other
capacities within maps
who have thought this through ahead of
time this is also
true with the the decrim movements
nationwide
and the various initiatives in oregon
it's challenging to think about
sometimes impossible the second
third fourth order effects of different
innovations different changes regulatory
modifications and so on but i think it's
very important because this is
not going to be easy and we're going to
need more than hope
you know as james cameron the director
said hope is not a strategy but
hope is not a strategy uh fortunately
though more and more people
are involved with this space who have
spent a lot of time
uh working on strategy in other areas so
i am optimistic but i'm not relying on
hope's strategy yeah
i thank you for that as well i think
you're absolutely right and
you know it could not be more important
that we as difficult as it is sometimes
and as much as we are struggling as a
community
especially right now to take our time to
make sure
that we usher these medicines in in the
right way you know they do have the
capacity to
spread contagiously we saw it in the 60s
and 70s and we saw what happened
i think even now there are if you really
want a comparison you know there's
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
people
dying of opioid related deaths every
year
and yet we are seeing more news
about people going to the jungle in
peru or in south america when one person
has or two people have a negative
consequence as a result of an ayahuasca
ceremony when they forgot to stop taking
their you know antidepressant medication
or
some medication effect that was combined
with the ayahuasca that caused a
negative result that resulted in someone
having either a psychotic break or dying
which is still extraordinarily rare and
yet that becomes something that the
mainstream media ends up associating
with these
medicines which is so unfortunate and at
the same time i think it just serves as
a constant reminder to us to be
extra extra careful i did want to
mention
one thing that stuck out to me about
your work which is again going back to
helping to destigmatize these medicines
destigmatize
trauma and mental illness in our
communities at large
one of the things that a lot of people
don't actually recognize
and i think a lot of doctors themselves
don't recognize is for doctors and
caregivers
we are not really allowed to admit
mental illness in fact
as a physician we can have our licenses
taken away
for having a diagnosis of mental illness
in our medical record if that ends up
getting reported
to our licensing board or if it gets
found out by our licensing board and we
did not report it
there are all of these different
putative restrictions that can
really impact our ability to even
provide care and this isn't just for
doctors this extends
to anyone who is board certified as a
care provider with a license
which is really quite destructive
because it really makes you realize that
many of our physicians especially on the
front lines right now are facing
symptoms of burnout but we can't admit
it or seek care
easily because as soon as we do we
directly
jeopardize our ability to deliver said
care and
that's such a wild paradox
in the way that we wound up having
ultimately as a result of that
more physicians and more caregivers on
the front lines who have potentially
untreated symptoms of mental illness and
we could have the alternative which
would be
caregivers and physicians on the front
lines who have
adequately addressed their issues um
because of overwork work related stress
or
the stress of training in the trauma of
training or whatever it might be
and yet that is not being addressed and
it's being in fact
punished because mental health and
physical health are still looked at as
separate things you would never see a
doctor lose his license for having a
coronary bypass episode for instance
which is much more dangerous and brings
you much closer to death than most
mental illnesses
and i was wondering from your
perspective tim as someone who is a
non-physician
kind of looking at this how do you see
our society overcoming this incredible
stigma of mental illness
i'm glad you didn't ask me how to
overcome the stigma as it associates or
maybe you are
specifically to licensed professionals
it's important to keep in mind this does
not
just apply to physicians mentioned
it applies to police officers it applies
to
airline pilots or pilots of any type it
applies to truck drivers
it applies to anyone with a license i
don't have a
quick answer to that i don't actually
even have a compelling answer to that so
i
hope other people are working on it but
i don't have an immediate
answer to that i can say that i
personally as a friend
worked with a police officer who was in
exactly this position
he was suicidal and he was on duty
carrying a firearm every day
sweetheart beautiful human being
understood how precarious that situation
was
and yet was not in a financial position
to go to his superiors and ultimately
ended up referring him to
a ketamine clinic for a five or six
intravenously delivered infusion
sequence which was
extremely helpful for him but the fact
that he had to do that
covertly is [ __ ] absurd and patently
unstable i mean that is systemically not
a viable solution so i don't have an
answer to that i wish i did
but i think telling that type of story
can
catalyze those who are in a position to
perhaps
make change or implement policies
whereby people can get paid sick leave
or otherwise not fear for their
livelihoods
and paying rent or putting food on the
table for their families
but i don't have a success solution to
that and just
so i can i can address my
flopping around with numbers 2018 an
estimated
38 800 people lost their lives to car
crashes 4.4 million were injured
seriously enough to require medical
attention so there you have the numbers
uh and i want to mention just one more
thing just because it's come up a few
times
i have a decent amount of exposure to
ayahuasca i would never
recommend that much less going out of
the country to south america
to consume ayahuasca as a first rodeo
probably not even a 10th period there
are very particular
risks involved that would take hours to
fully flesh out here but suffice to say
that if you're strapping on skis for the
first or even the 10th time
it's probably not a good time to go
house it's always to me
the thing i tell everybody is always
start low
go slow titrate up if you're going to
get experience with psychedelics start
with
the lowest possible dose in my practice
i actually start people out
on a pretty low dose of sublingual
ketamine and then graduate them up to a
psychedelic dose
and i found that like it's pretty darn
safe and people feel like they're in
more control
of their experience and i also have had
clients decide to go to peru
and say they're just they're ready to do
that kind of work and they have friends
they have guides they have reputable
sources and
i've had people who've had lifelong
depression literally
since they remember being a child being
depressed have
complete recovery so even though i'm not
recommending people go to the amazon and
do a bunch of ayahuasca
i'm still astonished by the fact that
there are miraculous recoveries in
certain people with the right guys the
right
set setting and the right preparation
and you know like i actually think we
need gateway drugs
that are safe and recommended by doctors
and
i think people need to put the training
wheels on i've always described it like
this you start with training wheels you
learn to ride a bike
riding a bike you learn to mountain bike
and then you learn to drive a car
and then you learn to fly a plane and
then when you have
you know been a pilot for a long time
and maybe you're ready
you could pilot a spaceship but i don't
recommend people go from a sublingual
ketamine clinically to like 5mu dmt
like that to me is super irresponsible
and there's a lot of people who don't
realize just how dangerous some of these
drugs can be
and i know enough people who've had like
you said their lives completely altered
in a negative way
to know that these are powerful tools
but they are also dangerous and they
need to be in the hands professionals
so it's kind of fascinating i feel like
the last 10 years in san francisco we
experienced this
kind of total renaissance of
psychedelics and there was a lot of
irresponsible behavior but at the same
time it led to
so many people figuring out oh my god
these can change the world
we can maybe bring these to market and
it's led to a much
more conservative and steady approach to
legalization there's a lot of work that
needs to be done and i just want to add
on to what you were saying about
physicians suicide dave
there's a great ted talk by a doctor
called why doctors kill themselves
and it's potent and it's powerful and
it's all about this
factor of doctors are suffering more
than ever
and they can't tell anyone and you know
it's
really a huge problem and i i think we
need these medicines for them too
not just for the patients but for the
physicians and so what's really cool
about
even ketamine assistant therapy and what
phil wolfson's doing what you've been
doing with him
is phil wilson's training actually
brings together practitioners
in marin and has them sit together
and experience psychedelics together so
that they have firsthand
knowledge of what this medicine can do
i'll let dave take it from there but i
think this is a really exciting time to
be a part of this movement
it is dave if you don't mind i'm just
going to jump in with one more
observation and that is use your
comparison molly
with the spaceship we don't need
everybody to be an astronaut
i'm saying that because i know you're
not implying it but just to underscore
this
there is to me a
comically imprudent cultural norm within
a lot of the psychedelic circles
which is you start with a you go to b
then you do c
then you do e then you do f
and you have to progress from starting
with a ketamine or an mdma
or a holographic breath work and you
work your way up to
psilocybin then to lsd then to this then
to that and then
at step seven you're at five mu dmt
there is
to my knowledge not a single indigenous
culture that does this
just and i've spent time with quite a
few
indigenous cultures who have cultivated
these medicine
traditions or certainly their own
indigenous
ethnobotany which can span hundreds of
thousands of plants that's also
easy to forget that these are not
psychedelic cultures these are
cultures that use psychedelics for very
specific
purposes which by the way have often
centered at least
in south america on warfare and hunting
so
just to put that in proper context but
it is not necessary
to fuss with every tool in the toolbox
maybe you just need to hammer in some
shingles
and guess what a hammer is going to be
fine for that you don't need to pull out
the power saw
and start cutting off corners of your
house which is what i see a lot of
people doing
in this space and it can be very very
dangerous if you think that you haven't
or you cannot be tumbled and humbled you
just have not met the right molecule at
the right dose i
guarantee you that there is something
that will completely unravel you
right maybe it's 5 mbo maybe it's
ayahuasca maybe it's 2ce maybe it's just
lsd
and you took 300 mics instead of 100
likes
i totally agree with that and also just
to
add a caveat that there are
contraindications to psychedelics i mean
there are
plenty of things that will keep you from
being a good candidate for these
medicines
like ketamine alone can cause
schizophrenic symptoms to emerge in this
thing called an emergency phenomenon it
can cause high blood pressure can cause
seizures
like there are risks and you have to be
fully informed
before you consent to any of these
medicines
and if you don't know what you're
putting in your body
you could have a really bad experience
and it could change your life to the
negative forever
and so these things need to come with
warning labels just like
all drugs have yet most people don't
read most people get prescribed drugs at
the pharmacy and they don't open up a
little booklet and they don't realize
that there
are all these powerful things that can
happen to you if you do is wrong you
take the wrong dose
or maybe it's not right for your body
and
yet we have a drug addicted culture
that is looking for the next big thing
and so we definitely don't want this to
become
okay this didn't work then maybe i tried
this if this didn't work maybe i tried
that and that's frankly the
psychiatric culture right now and it is
a big huge risk of this movement
because there are so many different
compounds and companies
literally every day i hear of another
company about seed funding
to develop their special molecules
they're going to patent that they're
going to figure out is going to be the
next big
drug and in psychedelics alone and so
there's a lot of
things that we need to be thinking about
i mean once one drug is approved i mean
we need to think about okay like what
are we gonna do when there's
15 of these and how are we going to make
sure that people don't end up
habitually consuming these medicines
thinking they're just going to get fixed
by taking a new psychiatric medicine
yeah
one more thing to add to that sorry
saying one more thing and that's 17 new
things but
the point i was going to make is to just
reinforce a lot of what you just said
these are very powerful
compounds they can be used safely
with proper screening and protocol
and if you approach any type of work
with psychedelic medicine in the way you
would approach getting completely
reconstructive knee surgery
or neurosurgery you will probably be
fine
you would not go on craigslist to find
your orthopedic surgeon to replace your
knee
similarly you want facebook to find some
shaman
to have you know unprotected spiritual
sex with you
uh and save your soul it's likely
not going to turn out very well and if
you
look at this just in terms of
significance
as you would when doing due diligence
and planning for something like
knee or hip replacement or neurosurgery
then probably kick all the boxes
of prep and safety that are
important aside from the compound
specific screening and
and so on that molly alluded to i'm
wondering
i'll let dave talk but i'm wondering if
we want to let some people
come up and ask a few questions i know i
just got a text from a friend who was
asking
tim specifically about why
he felt by that meow was the last stop
on the train
and i don't really totally understand
his question so i'm wondering if is it
time for us to
bring people up and you know individuals
want to ask questions like do we want to
go there or where do you want to take
this
i'm happy to answer some questions just
to touch on that person's question i
think a lot of folks
in the psychedelic community view 5meo
as like the everest of psychedelics yeah
i don't operate within that paradigm
so i have my own thoughts on five amino
dmt and its uses and abuses and risk
factors but
i don't view it as the last stop i view
it as another
tool in the toolkit with a much narrower
band
of application to a much narrower
segment of the population
yeah i think that's a great way to
describe it i think
you know just to echo what both of you
have been saying
um i think that you know what we're
really talking about if anybody tuned
into
our last psychedelic clubhouse with dr
phil wilson
you know we really talk about healing
from the standpoint of the restoration
of balance
it's not about becoming a cyborg super
altered state individual where you're
constantly
on the go go go and it's not about being
asleep or living in some fantasy world
for the rest of your life
it's about balance and the restoration
and maintenance of balance which is
really the recognition
that when we live so much
of our day-to-day waking lives separated
and feeling and perceiving a sense of
separation from our minds and our bodies
from ourselves from others particularly
the time of a pandemic
from ourselves and the earth and our
environment around us the plants etc
as tim referenced these cultures in
south america are plant medicine-based
cultures they live
in harmony with the plants they're not
psychedelic cultures
it's a difference in perspective of
balance in that
healing and the restoration of balance
really means the restoration of unity
a sense of union between ourselves
and everything else around us in the
universe which is something that is so
radically clear when we have these
altered state experiences
whether you're doing a holotropic breath
work or a deep meditation
or a mdma or ketamine experience or an
ayahuasca experience it's this sense of
union
that really brings us all together where
that boundary between self and other
whether the other is ourselves our own
intuition our deep inner parts of
ourselves that we were told not to
respect growing up because they didn't
get us anything
that we thought was good or whether it's
the earth around us or
or people in our family or or whatever
it is it's recognizing that that
sense of self and other is really a
perceptive capacity that is malleable
and can change and so these medicines
help restore
or catalyze the restoration of balance
in a lot of ways that allow us
to heal and so approaching these in that
way
with that foundation is critical
to make sure that we're always not only
respecting the medicine
and what the medicine has to teach us
but also respecting ourselves in the
process
because that's what's going to be most
likely to
allow us to have the powerful
transformative healing experiences that
we want to get out of these medicine
experiences and
i do want to respect tim's time so let
us know
when you have to head out we really
appreciate it soheb was
the first one to ask me to ask a
question so i'll let him jump in
whenever he's ready and then gina you
can go next
hey molly hey dave uh a really great
show i'm glad you got him on
um i've been listening to a podcast and
this discussion has
been very revolutionary i've discussed
in the past when i think molly and dave
we discussed a lot about digital mental
health and tech and the place of play as
well as
psychedelics so i just want to ask so
dave touched upon
medical residencies and burnout and i
think at the moment there's a study
going on
with the whoop strap um and it finishes
in 2021
but it correlates in kind of hiv with
cortisol
and saliva so i just want to take tim's
perspective on on
what he thinks about monitoring levels
of stress and burnout and
where he thinks there's a limit to
monitoring and if we if we can let that
data
kind of people we're working with or
managers is there a line is that worse
for our mental health and
with psychedelics would you start to
prevent that as you're seeing yourself
kind of going
above that curve that threshold falling
into a disease stage
thanks for the question uh and for the
the kind words uh i
am a fan of monitoring
and tracking that which is meaningful
and that which can be
changed so in other words there are many
devices you have
devices like the aura ring which i use
right now there are other hrv devices
that i
also use for resting state morning
measurements i find hiv very interesting
cortisol fluctuates tremendously
throughout the day can make the saliva
collection and reliability sometimes
challenging
but the real question for me is are
these levers you can pull
are they meaningful and can you
sufficiently
isolate these variables in
the mess of a multivariate
sort of chaos pie that is real life
outside of a laboratory
so those are the questions that are in
my mind
but certainly looking at different types
of physiological
responses both in session and out of
session
are very interesting to me it is going
to be an
extraordinary challenge maybe an
impossible challenge
to attribute some of the changes that we
were able to monitor
to a single intervention right was it
due to
the psilocybin session or was it due
to the therapy session was it due to the
daily journaling that started
after the therapy session was it due to
that single conversation
with a parent that had been weighing on
someone heavily for 20 years
it's incredibly challenging to trace
cause and effect between variables in
those circumstances
but as far as i'm concerned if it can be
done easily and consistently
the more data we can capture the better
even if they're slightly inaccurate
right the algorithms
are all subject to debate with say whoop
or
fora or any of these devices but if
they're consistently
inaccurate if that makes sense then you
can still plot
trend lines that are very interesting i
want to add to that
that i actually in my clinical practice
recommend most of my patients that have
chronic stress related mental health
disorders
wear a leaf therapeutic device um
you can find a link to it it's
getleaf.com it's a really cool hrv
monitor that is
it's a little bit different than aura
ring and and whoop because it gives you
hrv
visualization throughout the day so it's
a continuous monitor
and i'm biased towards continuous
monitoring but love that device and i'll
also just plug
dave's device apollo neuro which is
something i wear every day to modulate
hrv and i think these tools are super
valuable
as adjacent tools to helping people
triangulate
specifically where their stress and
their life is coming from a lot of
people have no idea
what's really stressful to them and then
they wear these devices and they say oh
my god i can't believe it's this person
that i
every time i talk to them i just have
this massive stress response
and it's a fascinating thing so for some
people it's their family life for some
people it's their work life
for some people it's their inner life
but figuring out where your sources of
stress are coming from and being able to
do something about them
um is paramount to healing right you are
gina this is tim reading gina's question
because we weren't able to get
permissions in time to use her voice
and here's what she says i'll paraphrase
here my question is given the issues of
the moment around sexism and racism and
the fact that a lot of sexism and racism
can be hardwired in the brain
and these substances can really create
the malleability
to possibly cure some form of sexism and
racism
have you thought of using these
substances raising funds around this
can we use things like mdma to address
sexism and racism
i'm going to answer that just because
i'm very well versed in the structure of
the medical system medicine today is a
pathology-based
program so it's all about billing and
coding for disease states
and right now racism and sexism are not
disease states you can code for
with the icd-10 and that means you can't
actually prescribe
for doing that but we do know that
racism increases risk of chronic
diseases
but there's probably not a good
indication right now for
us to be able to administer these
medicines for that one quick
chime in on that also and then we can
take a few more questions
as a primary outcome measure would be or
intervention
molly is totally on point so i won't
repeat what she said
it is possible in some
types of design studies to use secondary
measures or even primary outcome
measures related to conflict resolution
that are more observational in nature so
i do think
that the perception and sense of oneness
and lack of separation that many of
these compounds can produce
have applications to conflict resolution
and the demonization of the other and
within maps this has been looked at
between israelis
and palestinians for instance and there
have been
a lot of promising reports so i am
optimistic that we can see those types
of effects
they then need to survive as
fledgling blitz of reorientation
the brutality of re-entering the real
world
with its related pressures and habits
and sort of default tribal behaviors so
that is the challenging part having the
realization in the experience
less so ensuring that it has some
durability over
time requires very careful integration
i'll pass it to uh
eamonn next hey thank you dr dave thanks
dr molly and really appreciate
everything you're doing tim
so important um you talked about the
factionalism in the psychedelic
community and i think a lot of that
comes around
different perspectives of ethical
considerations coming into
commercialization
and i'm curious what you think are the
most pressing ethical considerations
that this kind of burgeoning psychedelic
movement
needs to come into alignment on yeah
thanks for the question so i'm sad that
we don't have more time to explore this
but i'll give my very very short version
first and foremost just as a disclosure
of sorts i have not
invested i've very deliberately not
allocated any money to any for-profit
ventures because i do not want to
have or be perceived as having any
conflict of interest
that affects how i think about or speak
to any of these subjects
and that's a costly decision
on my part but the one that i feel very
comfortable with
the ethical consideration there are many
ethical considerations we could talk
about
sexual abuse within the context of south
america
specifically it happens elsewhere but
it's at least as far as
i know the most prevalent culturally
in south america we can talk about any
number of different things
the most critical to get right
i think is the management of
intellectual property and preventing
broad claims of patents
such that we end up
in a entirely non-competitive
field or a world of psychedelic medicine
where there are only a handful of
players
who file patents to prevent others from
entering the field and this happens
elsewhere it is a known playbook
we have seen some of this already i know
people who are funding
legal teams to object
to via the patent office in the united
states at least and also
oversees broad patent claims but
if it becomes a land grab where a few
companies
who are aggressive with no
counter-balancing
opposition or watchdog opposition
are able to file very broad patent
claims where they
are perhaps capitalizing on pre-existing
means of synthesizing certain molecules
etc and they're
trying to do something from the playbook
of big pharma where they establish an
isomer they grab the right-handed
version instead of the left-handed
version and then they slap
a whole lot of restrictions around it to
inhibit
other players from entering the field i
think that could be catastrophic
and there are many different ethical
considerations but from a
practical what can we do perspective it
would be keeping a very very close eye
on patents that are filed for opposition
and having the will to oppose
patents that seem too broad for for the
good of the ecosystem so we have greg
and tash who should we take
should we take next oh great sorry you
can go greg as long as you have time to
operate about questions
yeah i'll do both i'll do both thank you
so much
this is tim chiming in again with greg's
question since we couldn't get
permissions for
his voice recording here's the question
thanks doctor thanks molly and thanks
tim
so this has to do with another current
issue of today which is kovid as you
know the global mental health crisis
that's going on and everything we're
facing right now
a ton of people are still isolated and
i'm one of them meditation has had a
huge positive impact
on my whole life but especially now
along with a lot of stuff i got from
your media tim which i really appreciate
i'm wondering if there's a way and i've
never gone into psychedelics at all and
i feel like it would have a profoundly
positive impact on me to even try a
little bit in conjunction
with the other positive explorations i'm
doing to try
to curate the best self that i can do
you or any of the three of you have
suggestions on what one can do if
they're still trying to isolate
and if there's any way to begin getting
involved and exploring
this process are there any resources for
that yeah i appreciate everything you
said and the question greg
my thought if you are looking for a
non-ordinary
state of consciousness that can be used
to facilitate
the beneficial manifesting of the mind
which is
literally what psychedelic means
etymologically speaking
mind manifesting there are tools
available that do not involve ingestion
so one option would be looking at
breathwork and breathwork facilitators
who are able to work at a safe distance
outside right so you could look at
something like holotropic breath work
and practitioners who are willing to do
something outside you could be seated
separately
there could be face masks if you wanted
there to be contact allowed
but there are means through breast work
and otherwise
of achieving non-ordinary states of
consciousness that one could consider
psychedelic without
ingestion of compounds
which i would not suggest doing solo
certainly without a lot of prior
experience
tash you're up awesome um so
i guess my last cycle looks experience
wasn't a kind of
positive kind as you can imagine
debilitating like nostalgia
and i'm just wondering if you have um
any suggestions for
overcoming like maybe previous like
let's say you molded the clay and it
didn't mold very well
um how would you like how would you come
out of that would you like try
the psychedelic again would you like go
see therapy what would you read that
kind of stuff
so let me ask a follow-up question what
did you take if you don't mind me
asking um i think like
two times a month okay
uh i'm gonna defer to the doctors on
this i'll just give you
my perspective i'll speak from personal
experience this is not prescriptive
right informational purposes only if you
have enough at bats
let's just say you are a clay spinner
and you sit at
a circular table you press a pedal with
your foot and you spin
clay every once in a while felt that
piece of clay is going to go flopping
over
and become a total mess and
if you have enough repetitions with
psychedelics eventually you're going to
have
a very difficult experience i do not
distinguish between
good and bad trips i distinguish between
safe and unsafe
trips so i would recommend first and
this is general it's not specific to you
but
doing some journaling with prompts and
questions
about you know whether it was a bad
experience or an unsafe experience
or a difficult experience within a safe
context if it is the latter then
there may be some juice to squeeze from
it whether you should use or not use the
same compound or others
i'll leave that to the doctors one thing
that i will say is
depending on individual tolerance and
sensitivity
there are certain dose ranges that can
be more problematic
than others for people and one might
think it is due to higher doses but
that's not always the case because
psychedelics
if we're talking about say psilocybin
act almost like different drugs at
different dosages
right so if you're taking a sub
perceptual microdose
let's just say of 50 to 100 milligrams
there's one effect
which is almost like taking an
anti-anxiety medication
it is mostly i would say a physiological
response and then you have doses going
all the way up to heroic
per terence mckenna five grams and
beyond
but a lot of people end up getting stuck
if we are going to use an
airplane metaphor so let's just say you
consume the psychedelic you're
in the airplane on the tarmac you
accelerate
you have takeoff it's a gradual ascent
you go through cloud cover quite often
there's a lot of turbulence and then you
pop through on the other side
let's just say that popping through on
the other side with
three grams or more would be the
equivalent of
of just cresting over the peak of the
experience or peaking
uh sometimes and it's highly individual
but for something like let's just say
it's powdered
homogenized mushrooms right so your it
could just be dried mushrooms
philosophy mushrooms for a lot of people
that one to two gram range is going to
put them
right in the cloud turbulence and they
will not pop through
and that can be very very unsettling it
can be very very unpleasant
a lot of emotions and material can come
up but you are
so firmly rooted in this ordinary
reality still
that you don't feel equipped to
metabolize them or work with them
so i would say there's also a
possibility although it seems that
likely with
200 micrograms of of lsd
that one should be cognizant of certain
dosage ranges
moderate range sometimes being
particularly challenging
but molly and dave do you guys have any
thoughts on her question
i mean for me two hits the bastard and i
am out
on another planet so for me that's a
dose tim you know i should say kudos to
you sir being a non-physician i thought
your response to that was
excellent really really really valuable
perspective
on how to approach this um and i
i think tash you know there again as tim
was saying
um the bad trips or bad
uncomfortable experiences from
psychedelic medicine or psychedelic
drugs are not always actually bad it's
just that they're difficult
and they need to be worked through a
little bit and they can actually be
stepping stones on our way to great
personal growth
if the right support is there and so as
a psychiatrist who works in this field
you know we i see this all the time and
one of my specialties not to make make
this go on any much longer but because i
know tim needs to leave one of my
specialties is actually helping people
um integrate difficult and bad trip
experiences so
if you want to reach out to me i'm happy
to chat with you personally and we can
talk through it or i can recommend you
someone who can be a good integration
therapist for you
who specifically has experience with
psychedelic medicines that can really
help facilitate
um you you know working through this and
coming out on the other side
i want you to know without a doubt that
these changes that occur in these
experiences are almost
never permanent almost never um and it
just requires
the right kind of support and the right
kind of of you know
uh collaborate collaborative effort
together to help you through it um
but you can absolutely get through this
as difficult as it might feel right now
um and just reach out to me at
doctordave.io
or you can reach out to me on twitter at
daveraban or on instagram
dr david raven and i'm happy to help you
or recommend you to somebody who can but
thanks for bringing that up i really
appreciate that you felt comfortable
bringing that up in a place like this
i think you need to be honest you know
about like the experiences and just to
let everyone know like it was safe but
difficult experience i guess it's what
you could say
so i think you know as tim was saying
like unsafe or safe and you know
journaling and meditation like i really
appreciate the
suggestions and i'll definitely follow
up with you so thank you so much
yeah you're welcome i'll add one more
thing that may apply to others and that
is
if you have a challenging experience
like that it doesn't mean
that you got thrown off the horse it
doesn't mean that your technique was
shitty
and in fact if you talk to anyone who
especially facilitator and you ask them
to describe
the more challenging experiences that
have gone sideways if they don't have
any
the reality is they don't have enough
experience
where they don't have a lot of
experience and
exercising trying to display as much
self-compassion
in these circumstances as possible is
very very helpful
particularly taking into account that
you are using lsd
which has a particularly tricky long
tail of low effect even
if we're talking about 8 to 12 hours and
i should say
that you know it's like one out of every
100 people will have a 24 to
you 36 hour experience that does happen
but let's assume that you're this is
called a normal responder and you have
an 8-12 hour experience for a lot of
people
the last four hours of that you will
feel
almost sober but not entirely and it can
be
very challenging similar to the one to
two gram of dose of philosophy mushrooms
to navigate because your friends are
talking to you they're eating crackers
and they're blah blah
and meanwhile like all of this sadness
from feeling isolated
as a child because a b and c was absent
and
all of this is welling up inside of you
and you don't know what to do
so lsd is i think
particularly tricky in that respect
because it has a long tail of effect
that can be very challenging so i would
give yourself also some credit in that
respect
because it's very common that people
challenge with that and
come out of it with the
the recency of the end the tail end
coloring the entirety of the experience
that is very common
that is very very true um and thank you
for adding that in
and tim i want to be respectful of your
time you've given us so much of it and
we are so grateful and so grateful for
all the incredible work you've done
the capstone um you know helping to
destigmatize mental illness spread
awareness
uh of the importance of mental health
and
prioritizing it uh to all of us and you
know taking the time to
you know to dedicate your your life's
work to
you know helping the world be a slightly
brighter
better place for all of us we could not
be more grateful and we really
appreciate you joining us here on
your first clubhouse
my pleasure i appreciate you guys
facilitating so well and inviting me
there's a lot more to come so uh much
more excitement coming
and i'm looking forward to some
additional
big news not from me but from other
groups around the country and if people
are
are thinking about or looking for a very
high
leverage place where a little capital
goes a really long way i mean you can
have billions of dollars of impact with
a few hundred thousand dollars i think
this is one of the very very few spaces
and there's
a window of opportunity right now so
reach out to people
like uh like uh david molly and others
who are
aware of attractive high leverage
places to donate or invest and
get engaged can't take the marbles with
you
and really appreciate you guys we should
actually take that advice and
we have started a web page to document
these stocks and i think one one
really cool next step we can take is
starting to list some of these
investment opportunities that
we have you know come across that that
could potentially really
move the needle so dave and i will get
on that that's really great advice
thank you so much tim for being here and
offering your wisdom
and your experience and your knowledge
and your personal anecdotes and
um everything you have to say has just
been really
inspiring and i think a lot of people
here this is our biggest crowd so far
so i'm really grateful to have everyone
in the crowd
show up of course this is my pleasure
yeah if anyone has any suggestions and
questions or comments on this feel free
to
contact me or dave um you know you can
find me on instagram doctormolly.com you
can find me
on my email i'm just google me i'm on
linkedin but um
tim you're you rock so thank you and
dave thanks again for
co-hosting this take care everyone
and uh to everyone on the
hall and elsewhere i suppose have a
wonderful week have
a fantastic weekend and be safe out
there
be safe and be kinder than necessary
i'll talk to you guys soon
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by the book how to lead
by david rubinstein david rubinstein is
one of the visionary founders of the
carlyle group and host of
david rubinstein show where he speaks to
leaders from every walk of life about
who they are
how they define success and what it
means to lead jeff bezos
richard branson warren buffett bill
gates ruth bader ginsburg phil knight
oprah all of them and more
are featured in his new book titled how
to lead
this comprehensive leadership playbook
illustrates the principles and guiding
philosophies of the world's greatest
game changers
in this book's pages you can discover
the expert's secrets to being effective
and innovative leaders past podcast
guest walter isaacson has this to say
quote reading this invaluable trove of
advice from the greatest leaders of our
time
is like sitting in an armchair and
listening to the masters reveal their
secrets
pick up a copy of how to lead subtitle
wisdom from the world's greatest ceos
founders and game changers by david
grubenstein
in hardcover ebook or audio anywhere
books are sold
you